foreign
welcome back to another amazing episode
of the careful boys today we have with
us from Christian Farina
welcome back Kristen thank you thank you
thank you very much uh you may not have
a quick answer for this one but
um I thought it'd be cool to talk about
who was the coolest person in your
school and where are they now
me and sitting right here okay easy
quick answer I mean it's kind of hard to
beat that outfit dude let's go you
weren't just like that in high school
though I was getting my ass beat where
are they now every day I woke up yeah or
who was like I mean uh none of us could
say that we were the coolest person
right definitely not I definitely wasn't
no I had a lot of friends who who did
you at school with Cole Hamels what's
that he's a major league baseball player
who won a World Series later on that's
pretty tight that's pretty sick I went
to high school with Eddie Murphy's Son
charlie
Christopher Christopher
I
feel like everyone who grew up in the
valley has some type of friend or
neighbor or someone that's a celebrity
or related to us you're out here already
like Wisconsin we got oddly enough he
wasn't the most popular is it miles or
uh Eric or Christian Christian oh okay
one of my friends dated him oh yeah
random yeah wow what'd they say
herself or maybe I just texted myself
and I didn't know I guess it doesn't
have to be relegated to school but like
when you were a a team
you know who this person when it came to
those movies Jesus there was like that's
a real life
there was like one cool guy yeah one
cool girl but I think that's fake
I think what I remember in high school
junior high is there were different
clicks yeah and there was the coolest
person of that group or of this group
and that's you know that's kind of what
I remember okay here's a person an
actual person I wish I knew what
happened to this guy but um in Cerritos
there was this one b boy I think it was
like I was like 15 at the time and
everybody used to talk about this dude
um and his name was Bon like b-o-n
and uh I think he was Filipino but he
was like for some weird reason everybody
was like yo this dude bond has flares
and this is when we were all still
learning windmills players were like one
level up from from windmill wow this kid
Bond got flares and we were like dude he
must be a God because back then it's
like that's basically like saying
someone can fly yeah like at this time
big deal to us yeah because we were
still learning Basics and then I
remember I went to some party one time
like at the beach and I saw him and he
was doing them and I was like that if I
was that guy I would be done with life I
would just be like this is this is it he
won yeah and he was like really trendy
like he kind of
um you remember when Cisco went solo
after Drew Hill and then he had like
silver hair he he did silver hair during
Thong Song like era
he bleached it yeah he he had silver
hair and everybody was like that is so
tight I don't even know if it was paint
or something but he he bought was his
hair and it was all like super silver I
think it might have been like sprayed
did that make you want to go silver no
it made me think like I could never be
that cool even though that's such a
dorky thing today no no but that is true
though that is true but he was like the
coolest of the cool
but I never knew what happened to him do
you ever maybe we should search him up
on Facebook or Instagram maybe we should
all see what the [__] what are they
doing now a lot of the coolest Cerritos
people like they kind of just did other
things but he was from a really cool uh
b-boy crew at the time that they they
had such cool names like one of them was
uh uh Dance Floor terrorists wow like so
cool this is probably like around 2001
too so it's kind of
this is
98. oh pre pre-terror pre-terrorism
ahead of its time but he was super core
of our post World Trade Center one
bombing I'm working through a bomb place
so it's still kind of risque in between
that time let me try to think I don't
know whatever happened to that guy but
he was super cool I don't think I've
ever been to a school where there was
that guy or like there was no person all
of the schools I went to except for the
private school that we went to
were like
you had over 40 people you had a ton of
people in class it just felt like so
many people doing their own thing every
yearbook has a person that's like voted
most popular in a way there's got to be
someone there there was no one that was
popular today you know the hot girls or
the jocks like but yeah awkward for me
because like I was the guy
hard huh no because yeah I mean I bet
you were the guy like what's the guy
what were you doing in high school what
was your amazing so my the thing is I
was a [__] loser my first year
because I was like super insecure
freshman type but then once I got into
dramas yeah then I like [__] was
confident boy all kinds of things were
cool I like was the lead in my school
played my first audition so then after
that it was just like oh yeah that's all
working everything's coming up Steve
so then
um I got apparently this is what I found
out later on but apparently I was voted
best actor which is crazy I'm not even a
very good actor but I was voted best
actor apparently every because I'm so
tall every year I was voted best actor
until I finally was able to receive the
award as a senior standout
the yearbook committee told me that you
won since you were a sophomore wow and
they always gave it to the runner-ups so
suck a dick everybody
cool thing to find out yeah
so I was like really I was like do you
feel like can you give back my three
years of honors yeah I didn't these
people didn't learn it they should be
stripped of their titles and you did it
because you couldn't get it because you
weren't seeing people thought I was a
senior because
senior yearbook
and as a sophomore people thought you're
a senior yeah nobody ever thought that
about me when I was a sophomore why are
we asking the prom King dude that's true
you were the coolest no I definitely
wasn't record you [__] piece the way
you look at me dude
I think I think it was a situation the
more I'm thinking about it I think it
was more of a situation like what Steve
had where it was like some other guy got
it but then I was the runner up I I
always forget that we're amongst royalty
and we actually have a royal person here
that's pretty crazy not like it's easy
to forget that no dude I think they were
there were way cooler guys in our high
school like yeah but they're all like
gang bangers and stuff so everyone
Pasadena yeah somebody's I don't know
how like what what extent they were of
gang bangers but like they were like
there are a lot of Bloods I went to high
school right South Pasadena is the nicer
the nicer area having a tattoo in high
school was already pretty cool because
it's so hard to get that yeah you have
to pull some weird strings under 18.
yeah pretty hard I knew a few shops that
would still do it remember how like our
school didn't have a lot of white people
yeah it was like mostly Asians yeah
there was one dude uh his name was Clark
and he was like they he was like the
only white guy but the stuff he did was
so cool and unattainable to us like he
was voted most like popular like cool
guy but what do you do like I don't know
if what he did was like play baseball
well that's the thing is I don't know if
to other people that's like very
standard but to us we were like dude
that's so cool he's like from the movies
because this kid would like uh at 15 16
he was already riding motorcross oh so
aborted yeah like extreme sports stuff
yeah yeah he did he like freaking
Monster Energy also knew how to edit
video like at the time he knew how to uh
like I could edit videos at the time but
I had to use two VCRs but he was already
using a computer and he did um he would
put like Fox Racing logos over like
superimposed over his videos of him
doing jumps over like sand dunes he's
got the poser dude that's so sick he
ended up becoming a firefighter too oh
dude what a cool guy dude
yeah he's a firefighter All-American
grew up doing dirt bike yeah Motocross
then became a fire man yeah so it's like
it's like everything that you want a
white dude to be when you're in high
school it's like we were like dude this
guy's so cool dude he's going to the X
Games I just know he will yeah and he
was just always above everything like he
he'd ever really commented too much on
anything he would just go yeah cool you
know what I mean like so you couldn't
catch him slipping on anything because
you don't know his opinion hot takes
yeah no hot takes yeah exactly like you
could be an [__] he should be like
all right doing your thing man
yeah he was just a cool guy I bet
Colleen was like that in high school
unbothered yeah yeah pretty much
you're pretty awesome I would just like
I don't care yeah I was just uh jump
from group to group so if like a group
had drama I'm just I wasn't about it
who's your favorite group that you hung
out uh The rosters
definitely all the white people for sure
yeah yeah yeah was your school
predominantly white I know it's pretty
mixed pretty nice oh yeah where'd you
grow up
um so West Hills technically but went to
school in Woodland Hills oh but out here
I picture your school being like
Clueless yeah oh no because the valley
it is the valley but it wasn't like that
although you know what was it like
although kind of though because there
were some girls who like wrecked their
Mercedes and be like oh mommy and my
daddy bought me a new one next week
that's pretty sight yeah that's pretty
cool did you did you have beef with
those girls
um
were you just like these dub [__] would
you like that
yes did you start like vicious rumors
about them yeah yeah
were you mean were you a mean girl a
little bit um I bet she was true no
girls were mean to me yeah why do you
think girls are mean what is that what
made you a mean girl now yes
you're mean to me did you do the dance
were you a dance drama I was in dance I
was in drama I was in all the artsy
stuff
yeah I used to make fun of Bandos
non-stop if you're in band Bandos
literally coming at you yep nobody cool
was in band [__] no dude well what about
that nobody cool the higher up you go
like the dirt chairs or whatever the
[__] the bigger loser dude everything
Biggest Losers of all was the teacher
why because they're fat with a tuba yeah
dude exactly exactly it worked the
opposite I think in in our schools like
if you could play a lot of instruments
they were you were the coolest person
yeah yeah wow there were some dudes that
could literally play any instrument and
you were just so cool no not me exactly
the marching stuff yeah we don't have
the [__]
thingy you never football team it was it
was because we had a flag football team
yeah no we were we were Ash no we were
Ash there was the cool thing is that
there's there's a such a shortage of
students that band would ask people to
learn other instruments to fill roles
whoa every now and then you'll get this
like Prodigy dude that could be like all
right yeah I'll just learn the bassoon
right and then he'll just like be a
different seat and you're like what the
heck those are the guys who go to Vance
Beach and they play every instrument at
the same time they got a piano harmonica
and a drum tambourine yeah they're
making so much money every day yeah how
big was your school like your graduating
class 60 people 60. yeah because the
soil was small I I got kicked out at
like seventh or eighth grade but it's
basically K through 12. oh so you knew
everybody no wonder you knew who the
cool kid was everybody everybody knew
each other very well it's probably like
the same thing as going to a school in a
small town yeah dude my graduation
ceremony too for [__] ever oh my God
that must take ages it was like hundreds
and hundreds of kids yeah that was like
ours ours was like 500. I remember
there'll be birthday parties and it's
literally like the whole grade the whole
grade is there yeah whole grade they'll
invite like the whole seventh grade or
something I couldn't even fathom by the
time when other other kids would tell me
like yeah my school has 3 000 people I'd
be like I
like I barely knew people I would
sometimes like see people in the Halls
had no clue who they were but they were
in my class yep that's crazy how old are
you
that way uh 25.
oh my God but I prefer it that way
because [__] already oh [__] oh yeah
dude because I feel like if you're in a
small class like you really can't escape
anybody yeah no I did my own thing yeah
yeah
like that but people were really rich at
my school like it was like a wealthy
area I wasn't like that but I was on the
cusp of it so a lot of people their
parents owned like huge Brands and
companies so House Parties weren't
insane right Lake parties boats access
to drugs in the wild Lake parties that
sounds crazy wow yeah no it was it was a
fun place to grow up were you a mean
girl no I like didn't talk to many
people eight months
I had one friend that got invited that
was like my really close I mean I had a
group of friends but like her family was
nope they did have money and stuff you
know making jello shots but yeah I
wasn't involved in school never went to
prom never did stuff I just was like
invested in dance you didn't do prom
either no I didn't do prom
I didn't do it either I mean I went for
like a moment uh just because you know
my mom wanted pictures
yeah you know going to prom suck but I
gotta love dancing so I was like [__]
tearing it up outside
you love dancing when Anthony's here
well I don't when he's here
dancing becomes a dark moment in history
[Laughter]
it's unpatriotic
yeah we're gonna talk about how we dance
around a bunch of dancers no no
embarrassing that's different social
dancing there's a lot of I didn't know
that we were dancing to Tim's wedding
yeah that was fun it's a little weird
like bust out into choreography when
everybody's just social dancing there's
a lot of there's a lot of really it's so
awkward don't do that really great
dancers that can't social dance yeah
it's a different thing that's like Dude
You're a drama kid right yeah that's
like okay drama kid parties we're like
yeah and kids are like doing monologues
and [__] because they're like too much
are you serious dead serious no bust out
monologue they have like a character
they've been working exactly okay is
there okay back to those parties is
there a hacky like monologue that people
would do all the time no
like the one I mean every model looks
kind of eggy right because it's all
drama monologues like it's all you mean
like Shakespeare [__] yeah because it's
all really from the back you have to
project from the back of the theater so
it's like it's like shouting acting
shouting the person in the first row is
like God yeah I've been to like musical
theater parties right yes dude oh my God
those should be attacked by Al Qaeda if
anything
it's like you're like remember like when
George W Bush was like they hate us for
our freedoms they hate us for our
freedoms I'm like they hate us because
of musical theater kids those kids have
too much Freedom what do they do bust
out into musicals yeah
they're just always they sing everything
they say to you yeah man I would have
been in there [__] punching everybody
for no reason you've been saving lives
for good reason I guess
I think it's great that like for the
most part a lot of artistic people
aren't cool because that kind of fuels
how good they get at a thing yeah
because they just hide away with their
thing and they get amazingly good at it
the shame is a part of it I mean what
happened to just getting [__] piss
Alice piss all like drunk and drugged
out in the garage and just jamming out
and thinking you're like a rock star
this is good with this thing to do too
that's normal I think it still happens
okay yeah
like what this just sounds like uh like
that movie that that that musical movie
where um it's like Les Miserables
they're acapella groups
the bells for me I don't know because he
doesn't Pitch Perfect yesterday yeah
yeah I like that [__] perfect yeah
yeah that is kind of how it feels
because I did I did Civic Theater for a
little bit what's that it's like when
you do musicals that you rip off from
real ones and you just have a whacker
cast and you perform it at City theaters
interesting so I did actual musical like
subsets of that you mean like a
community college thing not college but
like they're shaming you they're like
like if you think I mean no it's super
whack but like it's it's still funny
that you know have you guys so like
let's say you you know
for as a stepping stone like you go
through High School you do the drama
there you go to like Community College
and then maybe you get a role or
whatever and then you go into film right
or theater Live Theater you go to these
levels right have you ever been back to
like work on projects or something like
taking a step down yeah just because
you're just like bored to like do
something at your high school or like
any Community Theater level thing you
know what's what's funny is that we kind
of did something like that but it was
more
um so with Quest Crew when we would make
shows we would want to if we had a
really really big important show coming
up to test the material that we made we
would do a bunch of free secret shows oh
it's like we would do like beneficial we
go oh let's go with boys and girls club
and just perform for them so that we can
get the routine into our bodies and see
like how it goes and then fix things so
we would have a lot of like preliminary
versions of shows be seen by like just
random kids and things like that and
that way you don't have to feel like oh
I don't I don't have the I can't do too
many of these because we're not getting
paid so it actually like made sense to
take step Downs in a way but they
weren't musicals they were like dance
performances yeah I like to I like to
sometimes go a lot of the times go to
Just Community amateur nights to see
them really [__] do their best to
watch or to be in it oh not only to
watch but to also see how big-headed
some of these like American Idol
auditions dude it's [__] hilarious
not like Community Theater oh like a
poetry slam in a cafe or something all
of them like they really believe they're
celebrities dude and it's so good you
would have died watching my High School
production of Greece
because like our grease lightning right
was like a Ford Taurus and like it was
like like a oh that's the one that you
guys rolled Brown Ford Taurus because
like
you couldn't find a car we couldn't find
a car and like dude the best [__] though
was like they would they turned the
[__] car on right and like it's a
closed theater oh there's no yeah
they're [__] gas are like the first
five rows with like fumes yeah people
are complaining like like I'm getting
fumes and [__] and then like how do they
get that in the theater dude do we drove
it through the two double doors we drove
it all the way in the back but like I
played kaniki I was like doing the
Grease Lightning song and like because
in the theater version he's the lead of
that song yeah and so he he and I was
like dancing all over this [__] Ford
Taurus and I didn't I don't sing well at
all I was basically like doing an Elvis
I was doing that
that's legit it was rough and I can't
dance and it was rough ruff ruff ruff
ruff all around but he's still one
number one
and then I took the trophy for the state
okay
no no no that was a really rough
production but but that was the best
part is like it's like what do they
think this looks like yeah right like
but that's what I love the magic of like
of like theater acting and like musical
theater acting it's just like look at
this car wow this is this great this is
grease lightning it's just like I never
went in the front oh you could see
people just be like
it really is a you're doing it Peter
moment yeah like you can't suspend
disbelief because you got to sell it
right like you're gonna be buying it
doesn't mean anyone's buying it it's
like I'm selling snake oil and I know
[__] like did that [__] with you as a
kid like when you're trying to sell this
part of this big greased lightning and
then you see the front row people just
like uh naked faces does that [__] with
you you know I would love to sit here
and tell you I thought it was funny yeah
but it was really embarrassing yeah I
bet right but looking back looking back
it's [__] hilarious memorable yeah it
was so embarrassing and I was just
embarrassed like in general because I am
not a musical person uh so I must have
been a train wreck it was a [__]
nightmare amazing and there was like a
whole thing too because like the Drama
teacher hired like drama kids but then
the chorus people were like this [__]
up it should be us like we're Stingers
like why isn't it up and so so there was
like this weird like crosswalk going on
where it was like why are the drama kids
starring it and like all the chorus
people are going by like factions
like Whispering so you're like singing
up there looking at them like hating on
you yeah
worse and I'm like I know I suck I'm
sorry I'm like wait for dialogue scenes
I promise I'm doing like uh I'm trying
no dude that's the worst
but dude and I think about that
performance too it's just you just you
just think about all the cringy moments
right yeah there's no internet back then
yeah I know dude
and that's my favorite thing to go visit
and watch I know but not only that the
behind the scenes stuff that I know oh
that's the best that's so entertaining
so cringy man the worst is like for that
this one show that I had to do was a
musical and I think it was God spell and
then um we're supposed to oh God I hate
this [__] we're supposed to start an
audience oh yeah oh yeah you guys start
an audience and the director's like make
conversation with the audience member so
they don't know you're part of the show
okay and then you stand up and you sing
and you won't go up to Stage so
embarrassing so I go in there there's
like flash mob 20 30 minutes till show
and I sit next to this kid and his dad
and I start talking to them and the dad
just tells as soon as I start talking
the dad tells a kid he's part of the
show I don't talk to him
I just go
well all right
so sad son don't talk to these theater
people never leave you alone after yeah
they're freaks
your advice show like God dang great
start
oh